在這裡呢
我們要特別講一下
全鎮的陷阱
剛好趁著
這時候呢跟各位講
那我們來看一下
挑選全市場方向
全鎮陷阱是這樣子
這個我們在課堂上有提到
但是今天在這個
在這個平台呢
我們要講一下
全鎮呢
他有履約價跟行資比例
那跟各位講
履約價跟行資比例呢
在除全息的時候
他必須得做調整
舉例來講 我們來看這個原副好了
那原副這一檔呢 它的行思比例呢是1.006
它原本設計它的行思比例是1
那你看這邊的數字喔 有的後面都怪怪的喔
欸什麼23是什麼的喔 那都是
它原本設計呢 可能就是1 或是一個固定的數字
然後呢 在除全息的時候
它必須要調整
因為除全息的時候 你股價會往下跌嘛
例如說配5塊 配10塊
你的股價格連平盤價就要少5塊 少10塊
那麼為了公平起見 旅月價往下調
然後行使比例往上升
這個旅月價跟行使比例要做這樣的調整
那像這個行使比例呢
它往上調就變1.016了行使比例往上調呢 這個呢就會增加那但是呢 各位啊全正行事比例只能到小數點後面三位
就是在一般的股票裡面啦
只能到小數點後面三位
那個券商假如覺得他
他要吃點投資人豆腐的話呢 很簡單啦
他就把行事比例定成0.001
因為呢我行使筆定點0.01
然後他調整過中
假設我們多10%好了
原本0.01嘛
那調整之後呢
會變成0.0011嘛
那假如原本0.01的話
調整是變成0.011嘛
那原本0.1呢
調整呢就變0.1嘛
就假設要多10%的話
他會這樣調
所以0.1變0.1OK
0.01變0.01
這也OK
0.001變0.0011
欸 這個四舌五路變成0.001
所以有條等於沒條
有沒有看到
厲害了 有條等於沒條
來來來
喜歡0.01的券商 各位就要記得
0.01的券商是誰
所以我們把新的比例
由小到大排序啊恭喜 同一耶 我們同一從小排序開始都全部都同一在外流通愛非常多哎呀大家特別喜歡同一啊
這個
特愛同一
造勢造的好
行時比例0.001
哈哈
好啦你們愛就愛啦
我是不愛啦
哈哈我是不愛
厲害
喔
同一厲害
不只行時比例要弄你
還可以在隱含波動域弄你
哈哈哈哈
各種弄
哈哈
那個微埋隱含波動力一律往下跌
各位流通比81%
隱含波動力長這樣
長這樣
欸 微埋隱含波動力一直跌
就是他的回收價一直往下跌啦
有沒有看到
行日比例已經這樣子搞了
微埋隱波又這樣子搞
各種弄 各種弄
台積電隱含波動力90是
到底衝殺鬼啊
台積電隱含波動力90
我剛開始叫全任小哥的時候
我們的台積電的隱含波動率都是230欸
你看台積電隱含波動率90
然後歷史隱含波動率起碼才27
你賣到90
賣到90還可以這樣子
還可以隱含波動率從左上到右下
剛賣的時候78現在剩62
隱含波動率正講的時候
隱含波動率的數字喔
數字越低啊
這檔的全證價格越差
你自己看同一個波動率好不好都誰的這塊都誰的這塊不要說我針對他啦好不好我們看元大來元大
你看白白 他們的白白嘛
這47的白白
啊44的白白對不對
啊45嗎對不對 這正常嗎
欸 歷史27你賣45
OK啊 你可以這樣想
那個你的批發價27
啊你賣45塊我覺得OK
嘛
你統一是你的批發價27
你賣90幾
賣90幾就算了回收價一路往下掉
所以各位你要買全鎮齁
一定要怎麼樣一定要看一下
看一下喔這裡齁
欸一定要看這個齁
這一定要白白齁
微買引波要平平的齁
平平的齁好不好
各位啊不要買到微買引波一路往下掉的齁
這種特別的券商我們一定要特別講出來
微買引波動力一路往下跌
看錯時跌很慘
然後看對時不會賺
或是賺很少
就是這樣
他就是各種弄各種搞
流通比在外非常高
我是真的不知道
投資人打給你抵什麼
你要買你就買我是買的
反正你記得買權證不要遇到這一種
好啦
我們今天呢
又得罪人了
搞不好又要被修理了